don't cry mommy don't cry  dori dori dori - middle of the night dad  Dory sleep swimming she's talking in her  sleep  Deutsch there's a lot of things in her  sleep okay hand me the ratchet wrench so  I can fix it yeah when she starts sleep  swimming idiot I'm sure this was a  one-time thing  so can we just all go back to Dori Dori  Wow I remembered something  that's not possible is it okay is it  like a picture in your head and then you  think I've seen this before I just use  the word before which means I'm  remembering something what was I talking  about so my family they're out there  somewhere I have to find them  my remembers are they important  something important what something about  a clam or not no an oyster no mollusk  not something I don't know No